legend of the
secret legend of the secret legend of
the secret
this still isn't our dimension too bad
here we go wait stop
wait stop buzz buzz
pause pause pause pause hey
welcome back to there is no game all
right that's it here we go
hey the good the bad and the princess
wow home
[Music]
oh so sad i don't care stop by waking up
this character
okay
[Music]
we just have homes
not even that voice
is that you gaia spirit of the earth yes
it's
us it's me you've got a pretty
deep voice for a goddess i'm not feeling
well what's going on
the princess is in danger abducted by
the infamous dark lord
and held captive in the dimensional
temple
user that must be a way out wow yes hero
that's it let's go rescue
let's do that let's do exactly that but
before we do that i have to find the 12
sacred feathers scattered all over the
world
and slay eight ticklish guardians
and find 50 sun fragments what i say we
go straight to the dimensional temple
okay we'll figure it out when we get
there okay yeah we got this don't worry
about it
what is it the door's locked then
go find the key it must be around here
somewhere
okay i said this one's not the sharpest
knife in the drawer
stupid then kind of yes i
see it it's where could you have put the
key to the door
boeing blanc are you the one who's
making everyone jump your monkeys
oh what have you done
i don't know what did i do
that's grandpa's chest it was stored in
the attic
well open it maybe the kiss inside
[Music]
maybe
grandpa's carpenter's hammer what that's
odd it looks broken
ah looks like mr glitch has been here
it's okay my courage and my will are no
especially a key screw grandpa can i
whamp on this
whamp it how did that work did the
glitchy hummer
do this i guess i suspect that it
shrinks the sprite it hits
well that's handy ah oh i thought i saw
the key behind the dresser yeah i see it
too
behind the dresser wow
you are so dumb i can't reach
would have surprised me use her a little
help
yeah i don't know he's really dumb how
about i shrink the house
the wall how do i shrink the table
drink this strength of this
what if i shrink it twice and then it
gets up on it oh my gosh
hey you got it oh of course
i've got it it's about time go open the
door now
hero can you please we need to get on
with this like immediately
[Music]
what now the key doesn't fit in the lock
it's too big
unbelievable there's a key a door that's
as simple as it gets
oh i shrink him oops there you go buddy
it's open perfect perfect finally get on
with the game
yes we can of course i mean yeah yeah
there's no game here obviously
[Music]
verdant lens skips
the path to the temple is blocked by
these boosts do you have anything
to keep them with sword of life
might do it the villagers say it's in
the magic clearing to the west
here that sounds like a good idea yeah
okay let's do that
please oh
my god
oh my god what happened
did you not see the hole no i don't
think so
i've got to be more careful this
freaking idiot great don't please don't
please don't please don't
don't don't oh my god what happened
there's one hole in the path and you
fall right in
it won't get me this time oh my god you
should have called this game legend of
the lemmings
i can't shrink the hole can i put
something over the hole
no stop stop
i just don't move until we find the
solution okay okay
all right we're gonna have to cover that
and there's something going on here what
okay i could oh i could put something in
the teeth and then it would be able to
crunch up the teeth
i'm very smart my dudes
bam if we had the board we could build a
brick
yeah i know i know what if i shrink the
house
let's try to find a board somewhere oh
i'm getting to it
just hold your horse even if there's
something written with it
written on it what's that bag over
on the left inventory yeah i'm getting
to it
yeah hang on don't think you're so smart
you're not this is no time to be talking
about
thank you also weird
[Music]
if you jump in that lake and drown the
sword is on the other side of that lake
the villagers say that there's a sunken
palace at the bottom of this lake
but since i can't swim i'll never be
able to investigate
you will probably have to unlock the
amphibian skill
uh yeah but wouldn't it be better if i
could breathe underwater
oh i'm sure it doesn't have any intel
points so
then how are we going to get through oh
fun those lily pads are on their chains
oh i saw something jump oh
[Music]
wait but i did it but i did the thing
it's done
he can go across now jump jump you idiot
jump what are you doing jump
you fool
oh there we go that's that that's okay
that's what i needed
okay where did it come from the lake you
idiot it looks like the royal chest from
the sunken palace
that's what i call rushing a dungeon
yeah that's what i do
holy [ __ ] what is that the monocle it
belongs to the king of the abyss
it looks broken too that's unfortunate i
hope there's nothing wrong with the
sword of life
wearing a monocle underwater ridiculous
very
apparently this the developer's french
no you didn't plan it
i did actually the the developer's
apparently french
wow now we're making progress now we are
thank you
the legendary sword of life looks more
like a copy of excalibur
it's beautiful i hope i'm worthy of it
don't grab it by the blade you idiot
it's stuck come on yeah
try harder try harder
oh there must be some muscle underneath
those pictures probably not
banging oh let's make you bigger wait
let's make you bigger
you wouldn't pop into it oh yeah he's so
strong
i can feel the sword moving just a
little more and it'll come out
no no no make him bigger and me oh maybe
i could make him double big
no oh yup boing yep it moved the sword
moved
keep it up i am keeping it up i wasn't
talking to you
[Music]
i broke it unbelievable
do you know what this means gaia that
you're the most incompetent hero in the
history of video games
yes but probably
but it also means that this isn't the
sort of life
i'll never be able to save the princess
from the dark lord's clutches
all because of some bushes if this sword
isn't the sword of life
where could it be well i guess we'll
never gaia help me i'm begging you
give me comfort strength courage or a
pair of gardening sheers
hang on what are we gonna do with this
that job completely crushed the tip of
the sword now there's no way we're gonna
be able to cut
anything with it wait
wait wait a minute wait
oh your interface user yeah well you
know
bam the sword of life
it was on the life bar the gift from the
gods
it was the sword of life all along what
it's a sort of lie
a legendary sword of life yeah it's a
sort of life
really it looks like it's from the
galaxy far far away not far away
believe me no it's part of your life bar
i'm gonna try it
wow
[Music]
wow it works let's go cut those demonic
bushes that are blocking our path
well i don't believe it
he's doing it on purpose there's no
other explanation
i actually did it on purpose to save
time not bad huh
yeah just if only we all could plan our
deaths like that
kill the bushes or whatever
the path to the dimensional temple is
finally clear
to cut down two bushes
yeah well you know how it is he's one of
the infinite stark lords guards
no one gets through pip squeak my master
must fulfill the prophet
how original all right let's see what
this interfer
this sword does yeah let's see go whomp
him
and dad he's dead in two seconds
are you hitting me
well that ain't working longest fight
ever
and shrinking wham
boom and big hey
look at you you're as small as a bug
i'm gonna crush you he is tiny
that tickles kid
all right fine what are we doing here
what are we doing big
feather big sun oh that's interesting
ah fascinating
fascinating fascinating
fascinating wait hey oh
what was that all about
oh i've got a feather he's not gonna
stop breaking everything too is he
or fell down
it might be a time for tickling
damn he's just destroying it but that
sun thing is now that's interesting i
know
i know something about that you want to
get tickled you're gonna tickle little
dude
don't get tickled hmm ticklish guardians
oh
what was this noise it's fascinating
[Applause]
oh right of course ah
fascinating what i'm stuck
not for long loser could somebody give
me a hand
yeah which is easy easy peasy easy
posizly easy
wow we're here this is the entrance to
the dimensional temp
it's about time yes it is this is where
the princess is being held
captive but the passage won't open until
i found the twelve
sacred feathers and the fifty fragments
of the sun
stuff all right look there's a bomb over
there
to clear the way gracefully gracefully i
don't know if this is a good idea
trust me
[Music]
oh oh oh my god oh my god
that stinks a little yeah your health
has decreased
we will have to be careful yeah be
careful
yeah be no not him not him not him
and beginning ouch it's heavy oh no
ow yeah yeah yeah are you okay
are you okay yeah it hurts yeah okay we
got this this is the one
the princess it better be hot yeah i
know what you mean man i know what you
mean
go go go go go go go go go go go go
go go go vender oh i hardly felt the
thing getting stronger and stronger
she's obvious
can you please just go
not hang on wait wait hold on there's
something else going on here
what if i invigonate the bomb when he's
just about to get there
and he's dead
all right well i blew him sky high
yeah let's go come on let's go let's go
let us go let us go
all right so this we're gonna have to
walk through the old thing
again yeah well look man i was trying
but it was hard so
shut up eat a bag of dicks
shrinky but big grenade
thing wouldn't help at all it's too far
he will never make it to the door in
time yeah i know
that's what i'm working on
i'm trying oh right oh
oh oh oh if you would do
it which it won't do it what about him
big
regular bomb he has to blow up these
barrels you know what i mean
he's gotta blow the barrels
big blow it
you could quit dragging your feet
this is what he gets this is what he
gets this is what you get
this is what you get
[Music]
can you cut the uh he's too
way what if he needs to be teensy
cut through yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then i uh wait no okay wait no i
i no no no no no no no no no no no no no
he's big these are small
no he's bit he's oh my god i see
he's got to be big at first
and these have got to be small
no there oh my god and he's gonna run
through there
oh but he's in he needs to be small
oh wow yeah there you go no he needs to
be no he needs to be big at first
that needs to be small right now he
needs to cut through there
but now he needs to be smaller so all
right
cool you know what that's fine let's
make that big you're big for now
this is small then i'm gonna make you
you small
you small you small you smile but if
he's normal size he might be able to
make it through
[Music]
perfect damn it
yeah i get yeah
oh my god yeah i get it yeah uh-huh
come on yeah i know the funny thing is i
get it
you know i get it
go for it and i'm ready to make that the
biggest
freaking bomb in the history of kaboom
[Music]
there i go yeah whoever that is
dimensional temple princess
princess no princess inside no
dimensional vortex either
we're gonna have to work our way through
this temple okay
i'd like to but the door's locked these
switches aren't there just for
decoration
switches oh yes that switch must surely
open the door
nothing's happening strange hero oh
we nightmares
very slowly come on gaia we have a noble
quest to complete
i'm sure that the door is going gonna
open eventually right
big snakes big snakes
all right kaboom
oh yeah
[Music]
i heard the noise it must be absorbed
not funny
this is great stuff man this is really
good stuff
it's so quiet
you decided to sabotage the adventure
didn't you
oh here we go the door's gonna open any
minute i
just know it hasn't stopped raining
snakes
good thing honestly i liked it better
when it was raining russell
crosson yeah okay that i felt like that
was gonna be it and it turns out it
wasn't it
should have been it you know what i mean
ah go for it my man go
my my main me what what
what you both but the buttons were
pushed both put
seems pretty cut and dry bam
that one's green that one's red why is
his one red this doesn't make any sense
what's the deal eight hours later what
am i missing
i'll be missing
[Music]
i already did that but i did that what
what
[Music]
okay i did it
i opened the door and it took all it
took was patience
did you notice anything in the room
god [ __ ] damn it that was dumb that
was dumb and i hate it
that was dumb and i hate it we're
getting close to the princess i smell a
bewitching perfume i think it's probably
coming from the sewer
probably you know probably this room is
dark and i'm afraid of the dork come on
a big guy like you yeah big guy like you
it's not completely dark
you can see a little bit you can see a
little bit i already know what to do
a switch a pose button a pose button
all right hold still i will light the
way for you
you sir oh i see you wanted to light the
fire pit with the sun
ah i see i see it
[Music]
yeah yeah we're working on it
you did it i'm so smart
i don't know who that is please say real
names next time
the room doesn't look any brighter yeah
well how about now all right
i can guide him at least hey go towards
the light
thank you gaia very clever
i know i know
better hurry hurry
oh me gaia i'm scared oh big baby
big baby
i don't know what's happening well that
looks fun
that's neat something happened in the
other room
wow hurry let's go see do i really have
to guide you all the way to the line
oh my god help me guy i'm scared
a little baby all right look at that
wow that is something wait there's
something going on there
you're so overrated yep awesome i love
switches
[Music]
yep you got that right oh interesting
oh nito
oh fascinating okay all right
interesting okay this is four one two
three four he needs to go the other way
he literally just has to go the other
way around
ah we just figured out how to activate
those old switches
ah well this isn't right i'm
watching okay one on the right
i know you will have to do better than
that i
know
i got it i'm a genius did you know that
hey look did it
it's a key it's thanks to my special
technique of rotational
insistence i'm sure why don't you try
using your special object speaking
technique now
yeah okay
wow it's a big shiny key
must be the dungeon brushes key sorry
hero
we're gonna have to go through the
dock's mini room again
oh no not the dark room yes the dark
room
take your time
slow and steady oh this key gives off a
protective light
that's lucky it's very convenient for us
yeah actually that's very convenient
for all of us for all of us
hi who dares defile
my beautiful carpet someone who come to
rescue the princess evil dark lord
of the game i was expecting something
more
impressive i hear a voice
who is this spirit that guides you this
is gaia abominable dark lord
gaia no that's impossible gaia is
russian
uh okay uh let's see we'll invigorate
that
and beginning the fireball
nice okay well that worked i don't know
what that did
make it bigger
though i do agree with him on this one
nice
you're fast when you're motivated that
would have come in handy with big
boss
ouch hey that works how much longer is
he going to run around in circles i mean
it's working never gonna finish the game
at this rate
and anand nailed it find a way to stop
this projectile
no not that one
i mean you could throw them at him if
you wanted to we should use those bombs
to hit the bus
but i don't see how
spikes watch out spikes
oh my god oh wait wait i got it oh hero
hit him now
you're hardly doing him any damage
spikes watch out okay okay okay please
don't hit me
there we go sparks watch out i got it i
got i got it i got it i got it i got it
hit him now get him get him yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
on the bed one heart one heart left baby
one heart left a baby one art left
if i didn't die there would have been
very mad and it would have been my fault
i fulfilled my destiny let's go free the
hot princess
hey princess also there's treasure
you're free princess
oh thank you my brave liberator i don't
know you
and yet i can already feel a deep
connection between us
princess mysterious night
oh that's beautiful
[Applause]
because of their their love
wow it's beautiful it's something all
right it's
it's what i'd call something i hear a
deep sorrow in that voice
don't you have a princess to save too
not anymore
i once knew shall we say a princess
her name was gigi we were so
happy together unfortunately
she suddenly disappeared from my source
code
probably because of my cursed creator
since then nothing has been right
without her my existence as a game
program
is meaningless
now do you understand why i was trying
to drive you away
i'm just an empty shell
a nun game
i've got an idea let us give you the
contents of this legendary chest
maybe it will help you find her i doubt
it
yeah i doubt it too oh that's the bad oh
look gaia it's a
thing what is it
i was looking for a way out in all dust
chests
well there it is at last oh my
glitch
where is he going
three small changes in the game design
the kids are gonna love it
okay i will leave you now okay
[Music]
well i don't know i kind of like your
crunchy crunch cereal that's crunchy and
melts in your mouth are the same that's
really cool
can i have that spoon
okay bye oh
did we miss the whole thing oh
what have you changed in this game you
will find out soon
is it monetization sweet sweet
ad revenue oh
yeah we're gonna get oh
wrong playability scam faulty sending
cash champ
it looks like the game's restarted
what has he done
[Music]
oh
oh no he turned the game into a
free-to-play
we aren't gonna die
[Applause]
sorry sorry i got a little carried away
but being turned into a free-to-play is
the worst thing that can happen to a
game
how can i explain it it's like riding a
bike
but without the seed let's try to leave
this dimension
fast i mean if you're writing never know
it could be contextual if you're riding
a bike went on a seat you could
definitely just put the
the pillar there the seat was on up your
button and you'd be on there pretty
securely
so we can get out of here just hope you
don't hit a bump so a clicker game i
like that
okay another one allow the application
to access your photos documents bank
accounts and dna
oh absolutely thank you now
don't come on oh use your agrees
[Music]
agrees to spend as much money possible
and the game's paid content to squander
his inheritance the progress through the
[Laughter]
price access to the game is completely
free the user may make in-game purchases
to facilitate his progress but this is
absolutely not mandatory the game has
been perfectly designed for the fun
and easy play from the very first
minutes i have been day's gonna be ready
yeah i have wow
oh we're back at the beginning ah wow
the room looks different all right no
time to waste
let me wake up our friend and let's go
save the princess get up hero
i just made the bad move but i was able
to wake him up the first time
right ah oh oh my god oh what
the bet gives you coins when you click
on it uh oh yeah that's right
it's free to play now right
we should be able to use this money but
how
i did it alarm clock that's not an alarm
clock
listen listen hey hey listen listen
[Music]
freaking dead he's finally awake hey
what's up
what's that voice gaia is it you it's
guy uh princess in danger dimensional
temple dark lord
uh shake a leg
oh okay even though i'd have liked to
have my crunchy crunch breakfast cereal
first
cereal that's crunchy and melt in your
mouth at the same time
we don't have time for that we are off
the adventure hero
and fresh you're right let's hurry
what's with your speed my speed i'm at
top speed
boy don't you have more furniture back
then
i saw some really nice furniture in a
catalog but it was a little bit
expensive
oh boy
we will still be here in 10 years
is there any way you can go faster
maybe a new pair of shoes from the shop
would help
watch them oh
boy even the shop is for sale
oh my god i'm gonna have to download my
clicker
my auto clicker all right
shop shoot call oh my god your shoes are
pretty expensive
yes but it's the latest model they're
highly flexible and made of a breathable
neoprene
luxury apparently if you need money gaia
i can find some coins they're all over
the place
yeah i know you got them leaking out of
your dresser
don't bother going to find them in a
hurry to find coins
[Music]
ow okay
are they your size they're beautiful
let's not waste any more time and get
out of here we've got work to do
okay good it opens you don't need a key
good oh
we have to pay for the rest but we just
started
and it's not cheap that's a lot of money
well i'm almost there
yeah i just figured out why it takes
ultimate clicker
yeah me too i got it we're good don't
worry about it all good
unlocked baby it's clear again probably
should have gotten more
wait don't go yet no we need more ah
oh we're out never mind okay thank you
for taking all my money oh
verdant landscape starter pack
hey the life bar changed oh weird huh
hero what's the matter with you i get
tired quickly when i'm away from home i
saw that
your life bar dropped all at once i need
your help gaia
give me energy
thank you guys every two seconds
if i had eaten my crunchy green cereal i
would have lasted
that's crunchy and met in your mouth at
the same time
you like it too but we will get you
some okay we'll get you some crunchy
crunch don't you worry about a fake
oh i don't have that kind of money
hey look i have that kind of money eat
your crunchy crunch
a lot of
wow delicious as
always i need life
it's a sacred sword forged in the grand
tradition of cereal dwarves and for the
modest sum of here
let's go look for it in the clearing
the past seems to be blocked by a pile
of dirt
we would find a solution oh god i'm
gonna look around while we wait the
worst part is this is not an
exaggeration of
we're free to play rid of this bite of
dirt how
how could we can we buy some kind of
renovation
oh loot box i found a chest
i don't like the sound of that i don't
think anybody does
i'm sure it's full of amazing treasures
[Music]
oh wow mostly filled with amazing ads
oh we could win
ah okay what sort of trickery is this
the arrow moved by itself
and for once i had nothing to do with it
[Music]
don't cheat ever hey wait not that much
oh okay you already cleaned up a little
too much
yeah a little too much yeah fill in the
hole you just made
box
[Music]
oh
well you don't know that it could happen
it could happen it could happen there we
go
we're finally going to move forward yeah
come on hero
the pass is clear yay it's about time
no well there they go okay
they're building something probably a
parking lot
i hope they're going to build a bridge
instead because i can't swim
no there aren't any lily bats this time
preserver in the shop would you maybe
what shop never mind let's look around
what shop you said shop
you're the one that said shop load box
oh is that minecraft million
damn it super cool
i get it very funny do i just need to
keep making it colder
minecraft
wow nine craft
another one of those indie games that's
doomed to fail
yeah oh my goodness
what are we looking at here
very very interesting
exactly
yeah hey hold on you hush your face
yes it will help it'll help
[Music]
hold i bet there's a tiny chance of
getting the million
bam i
there are other ways to break the ice
you know
isn't that right sir he's dead super
i think he needs to chill out you're
very funny but he is dead
crazy
you're amazing gaia you even control the
seasons
uh i didn't need any money for that one
that was dumb the sword isn't here
oh i think we have to choose
i think how about the snake blade that
sounds
cool i wonder what the legendary sword
of life looks like
[Music]
all right screw me then i guess i was
wrong
can you find the money gary please
no need to help us snag all right
i won't move what a graceful form
but it's made of plastic isn't it i'm
gonna try it
the sword broke great
oh look there's something new in the
shop of course
we break something and they offer to
sell us the upgrade but
the price is in dollars you have to buy
it with real money from
the real world i'm warning you user i
don't have a pay please account
and i've got no cash on me i was quoted
without pockets
and i don't think i can find any dollars
here
well i will
get it out let me just pick that dollar
sign off of there
just pick it out pick it vintage
try blade
dollar baby wait wait for it
wait for it i didn't the the answer is
here
the answer is here how can anyone not
see how in front of me that is how
it's so clear here it is it's in front
of me
i see it the answer is right there
yes what are you doing with that sword
oh there we go decorating user i might
be looking for a way to play it
looks funny it's like uh
it is
i'm gonna try it wow it works finally
getting somewhere
we're gonna be able to clear the path in
front of your house
[Music]
ah he is doing it again
oh what but
we're back to detect your screen uh oh
have we used up all our lives
uh-oh these try to plays are rippers
oh energy bar depleted three
diamonds you should oh now they want us
to pay for diamonds
and of course we don't have our super
bag of dollars anymore
we will just have to wait until the game
gives off some
smart way to increase the playing time
okay
i see a diamond got one a diamond
perfect
you see user when you hit something
order the iphone with it
it pays off i'm sure you will be able
there's a diamond right on the scene
dab it right there dab it literally on
there here's the diamond bam
got it yeah i'm a genius there you go
there i go you don't have to wait
we can keep playing for free easy oh my
god
looks like we're gonna have to wake him
up yeah i know i know i know i know i
know
what's that voice gaia is it you're
gonna
oh no no i'm kidding
i will kill you now that i have the
sword of life let's go free the
princess we're not here to have fun no
way man
do i need to actually get any coins
before you move on i don't think so i
don't think so the path to the devil is
finally clean
again
[Music]
oh she's one of the infamous dark lords
scars
i won't let anyone in i won't let anyone
in
unless of course you're a pioneer member
oh you're not
i'll destroy him in one fell swoop with
the legendary 999
ward okay okay
let me build up my economy here
lalali lulu
lower
nice
raise still doesn't do anything to him
right oh
ah smart
oh all right he gave you quite a bit
hardly felt it oh interesting
he broke that barrel to get out of the
way
so what's i gotta do let's get ready to
plop it down on him
oh no that was too early damn it
ah i see i have to give him the out
to lower it i got it i got it
here here lower and oh the barrel
nah the barrel needs to be there and i
need to buy it guy
i know i know i know
get out of here
ah it doesn't look like he's coming back
down
good riddance what do you mean it
doesn't look like he's coming back down
what
[Applause]
we finally reached the dimensional
temple wait the door is wide open sure
looks like it
maybe it's a death trap yeah probably go
ahead
go on in i will watch you i'll watch you
too
oh you knew it it seemed too easy
so how much does it cost this time how
much a million coins a million
coins it's gonna take a while but it's
doable
let's get to work no way we're gonna
farm one million coins
oh i'm gonna get it what are these other
things wait please
i'll i'll get the millia don't worry
i'll get the
please paper please babe
hello
that's very funny that's very funny that
is
very funny that is very funny
anyway time to get my economy up
oh he's talking oh he's tuckered i just
want to see what this other one is
can you imagine me thinking
no okay i'm gonna get that million but
i'm gonna get that bomb
well that's
well that wasn't very helpful
wonderful oh what if i make him fall
no he is the paper i can give
paper to the other paper please i think
i have to
time it when he's about to fall over
now someone's gonna wipe their butt with
you
you're gonna get pooped on you're gonna
get wiped in a butthole
you're gonna get butthole wiped
that's so sad for you oh that's so sad
for you man that is really sad for you
here you go there you go oh oh
hello oh they thank you thanks for the
gift
say thank you
something here no
oh wait oh
i get it that makes not sense but it is
a thing
a max wait a minute max see how max is a
it's a little bit of a cheat you know
what i mean
you want a million coins i want a
million dollars we're rich
to spend it all in this freezer
yeah yeah yeah damn
easy easy i think i found enough coins
we can finally access the dungeon
you're very powerful that's a good ear
oh and he started
cutie who's a little cutie there's a
little cutie there goes my coins
all right cool
[Music]
premium content is here already
perfect
[Music]
i don't know i don't know i don't know
why anything is done in this place
i just click columns get coins because
that makes sense i'm gonna put a moon on
the floor
never mind moon mode oh no it's too dark
[Music]
wait there's something going on here
also let me see if this is a real
qr code it is not
interesting okay but it is it is the
answer so it's
it's doing doink got it nailed it
too easy i've just forgotten it i didn't
actually take a picture of it god
damn it no
oh
oh what the hell did you just do
why did you just do that okay i better
take a picture of it this time
what if i just buy one at a time you
know maybe that'll be it
this one try that one
okay light it last
this tile appeared weird huh very
strange
two lied at last
boy this is tedious
maybe if you bought him in the right
order he would actually press him i have
no idea
but i don't trust him floyd at last
at last light at last light is lying
he's tired god
damn it hi bud thanks bud
[Music]
oh wow is that all you got fantastic
crunchy crunch
cereal it was getting a little hungry
[Music]
why did that cut them
oh i see interesting
so that one's missing a three
three four one
two so what i think it is is it's
one two three four one
two three four suck
remember how they came in lie down last
[Music]
well oh wait he didn't press the right
one did he
he was supposed to press this one so you
do have to do it
no okay well that's weird much later
okay so that is the first one
i'm not sure why much much later
oh oh my god okay
i get it i was thinking about too small
scale
it's only looking at these two columns
right i was thinking very differently so
then
it's two three four so
okay let's go i'm not gonna try to
do it differently just one at a time
and kaboom i'll be getting more cereal
and my
energy dick goes huge i'm gonna knock
that key right off of there
ah there's another puzzle
you will be the one who needs some paper
yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh
wow oh wow official guides
fully illustrated huh oh oh wait wait a
minute
oh wait i'm ready with my camera hang on
wait hang on wait
watch this oh
come on no way okay got it
done it done so okay
watch this
let's see if this works let's see if
he's smart
[Music]
nice he actually does do it
wow more cereal bigger energy what's
that secret in the bush what's the bush
secret what's the secret in the bush
what's this bush in the secret what
secret bush
he just fell to the floor hurry up i
said it
did you see that user we're lucky it
fell down
yeah we're lucky ah lucky
the room is too dark anymore
they've probably got costs
oh free gift son
son all right well this is easy
i can't open the door some kind of long
bar is blocking the door
are you talking about your energy bar
who about the cereal something's a
little bit too far
open out there's got to be a mechanism
somewhere
but i don't see anything in this room
that could help us
then again it's really dark come this
way
i'll switch i'll probably have to go
activate it
well come on then i should oh my god
you little baby baby baby
i'm afraid of the door
all right oh don't you worry we are
on this i got a big chompy
chompy oh he's got a key chompy with
nose
nose chompy i don't know what knows
chompy do but i love him
tickle tickle nose chompy
oh i got oh that was a i just had to
grab it okay i didn't
shrink us finally it's clear
open the door quick quick ha at last
well that wasn't very quick
hi who dares to file my beautiful
it's currently on sale for 19.99
someone who's come to risk i can't see
you anymore who's talking to me
i can't see with this bar in front of my
eyes
there that's better where was i
oh yes you seem to be forgetting what a
warrior needs for a dude or death
oh yeah but also vitamins uh b1 b2 and
b5
naturally present in crunch crunch
cereal the cereal that's crunchy
you're right gaia enough talk come and
fight prepare for a long and painful
fight
okay how painful how long oh
well all right um
[Music]
you mean easy you mean to wait he was
defeated by the power of love
ah princess
is there 18 plus dlc in this one oh
thank you my brave liberator
i can already feel we've heard it before
[Music]
wow feel like we've been here before the
exit has appeared again oddly enough
yes finally gonna be able to leave
finally yes
thank you brave hero for your help
thank you it was an honor guy i hope you
two live happily ever after and have
lots of little sprites
let's go user let's not hang around yeah
let's not hang around
oh i don't believe it even exiting the
game costs money
oh i get the feeling there are no more
keys in stock
mr glitch well played we are stuck here
forever well maybe there's a key in the
legendary chest
oh it's a map
that's the map the region great the game
map
ah the wait until we have done with the
adventure to give us a map of the game
and a blank one too blank but
free we need a key to unlock this last
dlc
let us search the area from top to
bottom
oh i'll be able to find a solution wait
a way to wait a minute
wait a waiter wait a minute i know
of a little bit of a secret uh
apparently here squirrel
ah okay is that it okay
all right well oh wait wait wait wait
wait wait there's apparently
oh what's what's what's um huh
there's something going on here maybe if
i blow up the house
if i just complete the map is complete
but wait we're not going all over the
place and there are no keys in sight
uh-oh
here we are stuck for eternity in the
free-to-play
free to play man this portuguese guy is
real
couldn't imagine a worse scenario for
the rest of my existence
even being stuck in ship simulator would
have been heaven
compared to this i'm very sorry user
i'm not well what can you do
for a klondike bar the shape of this map
is strange
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh i would never have known that in a
million years i never would have gotten
that
this [ __ ] for this market you know you
had to add that in because
no one got it you unlocked the dlc
hilarious oh thank you thank you thank
you you're welcome you're welcome you're
welcome it doesn't matter my friends
we're living again i hope this time you
can finally go home guys i'm 100
sure this is finally the right thing
finally thanks
again for everything thank you farewell
our companions finally made it home
thanks to cooperation true
friendship and an unexpected
lack of budget
the end
[Music]
whoa is that really the or is it is this
a trick wait
hang on a second no
it's over already what with this lame
ending that's
i knew it this sucks hey i bet it's
because of the crowdfunding campaign
failure
i hope you got me on sale because this
is bordering on the sky
and wait hold your horses
get out of this raven phone dammit i'm
not
sure the music's familiar
but what's with all these russian names
who are these people or do you know what
this means user
it means we're still in the wrong
dimension ah
i
[Music]
what is he doing
i knew it oh
i knew it i knew it
he broke everything even before you
managed to do it
well as much as i'm not afraid about it
we're probably going to need him to find
our way out
oh okay all right then okay oh
all right that's all the time i have for
this episode it looks like i think
there's a total of six chapters in the
game
i think just judging by and it almost
got me there it almost made me think
that that was the end
but looks like we got another two
chapters to go so we're gonna finish
this up in an epic third part
thank you everybody so much for watching
i love this game it's super fun
i can't wait to see how it ends it's
gonna be really cool i didn't know their
crowdfunding campaign failed did it is
that true
oh i didn't even know there was one
anyway thank you everybody so much for
watching look forward to the conclusion
coming at you very soon
and as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
[Music]
you